as we head into this holiday week we
wanted to reflect back on what has
happened
over 2020. it's been a crazy ride
this last year with all the uncertainty
and things happening and
the world changing and so sean cannell
and myself decided that we wanted to
give you
what we've learned in 2020. my name is
heather torres and i am the host of the
think marketing podcast and if you're
new here i want to welcome you
we release a brand new episode every
single tuesday
so if you are new make sure you
subscribe wherever you're consuming this
content from
now like i said 2020 has been a
roller coaster but there are some great
lessons that have been learned
over this time and as leaders i think
it's really important that we reflect on
what we've learned
so grab a journal because this one is
five lessons that i've learned over
2020 and i'd love to hear from you in
the comments if you're watching this on
youtube or
in the apple review if you are listening
on
podcasts and let me know what are some
of the lessons
that are takeaways for you well this
episode is also brought to you by our
think
master class over this holiday season if
you have an extra hour of time for
learning
which you should be putting on your
calendar make sure that you go to
thinkmasterclass.com so that you can get
the three lessons to youtube success all
of the changes that have happened on
youtube
over this year and how you can succeed
if you're starting or wanting to grow
your youtube channel
this next year sean cannell the ceo of
think
does a phenomenal job in this hour class
to help you grow and
succeed on youtube alright let's get
into today's featured conversation
[Music]
heather i'm excited to talk about five
lessons you learned in 2020 i mean 2020
was a crazy year
and um a lot of challenges a lot of
things
none of us have ever experienced before
none of us could have ever predicted
personal issues business issues family
issues cultural issues election issues
but i know that our theme at think media
was really how do we adapt how do we
pivot and really what are the lessons
that we can learn
for good how can we see the positive
perspective
and use hard times to potentially create
momentum
in our businesses in our youtube
channels and so you have five lessons
and the first one is change is the only
constant what do you mean by that yeah
change is the only constant
is to me it just means that every time
you feel like you're in a flow
every time you know you think okay this
is the way we're gonna do it we need to
change
because change is the only constant and
if you live in that world if you just
know that
what happened yesterday probably won't
happen today or just knowing that
um that there's always going to be
something changing and never living
in the well we don't do it that way or
that's not how we've done it in the past
and you live in the expectation of
what's to come then
you have the opportunity to see it as as
an opportunity and not as a disadvantage
and so i think it's really important in
2020 when we look at
everything that happened when you know
our business started to really change
in march that we looked ahead and we
said what can change
you know who needs our help how can we
help them better how can we lean in more
into what we offer here at think and i
think that
knowing that change is always going to
be constant is key i feel that in my own
personal life too
raising three kids homeschooling them
you know it's in your new dad so it's
almost like week to week
something is changing with him right and
so even when you think about okay i've
got my parenting going right
i'm really synergizing with this child
and this child
and then this kid does something right
and there's always going to be change
and so
i like to just live in the expectation
of not
in the uncertainty but just in the
belief
that it's going to change and that
change is a positive and not a negative
and what are some of the changes that we
made at think media you know ones that
stand out to me
that you know crisis has the opportunity
to reveal
potential weaknesses or areas that we
could strengthen in our business
i think it caused us to tighten up our
communications
especially because now we had to
communicate we were already remote which
was a blessing
but we had to communicate in another
level so we started to communicate more
with each other
with our community we started new things
what are some of the
changes that you think were positive at
think media that even
people could apply in 2021 maybe to
their businesses yeah i love how you
said number one was
communication i think that is huge
whenever there's change
it's not communicating once it's
continual communication so one of the
things
we didn't think is we always kept the
goals
in the forefront we were really talking
about not just the challenges that were
happening
but the successes that were happening
and so i think being able to communicate
between teams between people
um we were also really uh like you said
we were
adding new things and as we were adding
new things it was developing
more in communication allowing for our
team to
have some mental time but also to keep
them focused on what the end goal
was and so i think another thing that
changed too was we went deeper we're
going to talk about this in the next one
but we went deeper even more so than we
had before
by using the technology that was in
front of us and we
actually onboarded some additional team
members during this time so that was a
change
um we also onboarded different systems
so that we could communicate better
and allow for our team to move faster
with the things we were doing
i love that which is number two a lesson
you learned from 2020 which was
prioritize people what do you mean by
that yeah i think a lot of times when
you're put into a stressful situation
this is my personality at least
uh when i'm put into a stressful
situation i sometimes
like to guard myself but that actually
means pushing people away and i go
insular and i think one of the lessons
that i really learned in 2020
was the idea of allowing people to be
the priority
so i was putting more time in taking the
focus off of myself
and putting the focus on the people that
mattered most to us which was our
families and then
beyond that our customers you know
helping them realize
that even though the world is changing
and things are crazy that they
still had the opportunity right in front
of them so just bringing that reminder
back to them
so it was our families our customers and
our community i think it was really
important that
you know we've been able to foster a
very active online
community and so keeping them active
rather than
watching the news all day watch some
think media videos you know the idea of
putting your priorities still in place
and not backing down from that and i
think by being able to
prioritize people 2020 for me was a
growth year
2020 for me while it was a challenging
year we also just went deeper as a team
we went deeper into our family
i know in yours you said you know you
had more hikes with your wife than you
ever had before
same with our family we really had a lot
more uh
family time together and i think the
last part too was really honing in on
our network
uh we love to travel we like to go to
different conferences and events that
wasn't necessarily happening this year
and so it was really making sure that we
were setting aside the right time
especially for me to network with the
people that were important to me so
making sure that i was checking in or
that i was you know getting on a zoom
coffee date with a friend or something
so that i could still continue to grow
my network and one of the things we did
this year was
we hosted a few different challenges and
i think what that brought
to our community was the ability for
them to network with each other
we also hosted growth video live this
year which was all digital
and that allowed people to connect and
network with each other as well so just
allowing for different opportunities
for people to be your priority when you
take the focus off of yourself
and you put it towards helping other
people i think that that can actually
enrich your life more
man i love that and that's something we
could all learn from it just like you
it's easy when times are hard and when
the news cycle is so toxic and when
things are so crazy to want to hide
under a rock
it's like come on let's it's like
netflix ben and jerry's
let's lock down um but people
we need each other and we need
encouragement um and one of the things i
tried to adopt
was the role model mindset and just
thinking about who needs me to be strong
or who needs to be encouraged
one of the best ways they say to like
build
good friends is to be a good friend and
so
i know in 2020 we maybe wish we got
encouraged more or got text
more or got you know somebody in our
instagram feed encouraging us
more but the question is how can we
potentially prioritize people because
people matter most and i love that so
much number three
is overcome paralysis by
taking massive action tell me about this
lesson
yeah i think uh by having the leadership
in
our already in our company to be able to
take massive action
a few things we do here at think media
that i think everyone should do is we
write down our goals consistently
we always have our goals in the
forefront and when it's taking massive
action
you know it kind of goes back to the
idea that when change can happen or
uncertainty can happen
that paralysis can start to set in you
don't want to make videos
you don't want to write the next script
you don't want to connect with people
you really are working on um yourself
rather than thinking about well what
what is the opportunity in front of us
and i think
one of the things we learned in 2020 is
we already had everything we needed
we already had the cameras we already
had the gear we already had the internet
connection
so why don't we start doing things why
don't we start taking more action
and you know our plans changed we had no
challenges on the calendar for 2020
but when it when the lockdown happened
when things started to
go sideways in the world we thought okay
well how can we bring people together
what do we have access to and so i think
about overcoming
paralysis by taking massive action
really means
writing down what do you already have in
your possession that you could be using
as the tool
to do the thing you want to do so if um
if you
if you had you know you were laid off
your job or
you were just in a position where you
weren't able to work
well let's make some videos you know and
i think that was a big part of it
and for me taking massive action was
sticking to the things that i knew
were great like my routine in the
morning like my routine at night
like my um dates with my kiddos right
like still making sure that the things
that mattered most to me were still
happening and i was putting more time
and energy
into those things man that's so powerful
and i think about like literally the
physics law
of objects in motion tend to stay in
motion
and objects that rest tend to stay at
rest the law of momentum
and when we had the government and
potentially
governors potentially your job or just
different things that maybe caused
things to come to a halt our economy
came to a halt maybe your business came
to a halt
it is up to us momentum is hard to build
but it was up to us to actually create
momentum
to keep momentum going to maybe
potentially double down on working twice
as hard
but to overcome paralysis by taking
massive action i think that's something
that think
marketing community ask yourself um what
do you need to take massive action
on stop pondering and start posting
start start just leaning in massive
action and
action is the antidote uh for reaching
your goals you gotta actually just step
out punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face press record
go
live build your business even though
it's scary and if you're waiting for
certainty you'll be waiting your whole
life
so good it was such an uncertain year we
had no clue what was around the
the future i remember those zoo meetings
with the team and stuff and i'm just
like grin and bearing my teeth
i hope this works i hope we're meeting
in two weeks i hope things keep going
but we just kept taking action and we
kept moving forward
and i love that lesson and i think
that's an important lesson all 2021 when
we're gonna
encounter many more challenges probably
similar to 2020.
all right number four obstacles breed
innovation tell me about that yeah you
know i think
being open to uh uh kind of repeating
the same thing with the idea of just
being open to
innovating in your company you know i i
loved um
when the i didn't love when the lockdown
happened don't hear that but i
loved seeing the innovation from
different businesses
you know uh someone we know was a um was
talking about in her community
she had a spin instructor they owned a
gym well all gyms were closed so what
did she do she started
leasing out those the gym equipment to
the people who used to be in her spin
class and she was doing them online
so the idea of still staying innovative
in your company when
you have something coming up against you
an obstacle coming up against you
what are the other opportunities how
could you pivot your plan
to make an impact in your business so i
think 2020 really taught us that
we have the opportunity to see the
obstacles that are in front of us
and then collaborate and come up with
new innovations and i think that the
think team did a great job this year
really thinking about how can we
innovate in our business you know we
really
took the content we were making to heart
like we really focused on well what's
gonna drive the needle what's gonna help
people the most and
we really went back to the basics and a
lot of times in innovation
you think it needs to be the new cool
flashy thing
but really what it could breed is the
idea of innovating within the restraints
of going back to the basics so good
think marketing ask yourself how can you
innovate
even in the midst of maybe tough times
or maybe if one door is
closed what potential other doors have
opened for your youtube channel for your
topic
i love the story from this year of
canlis a restaurant that's in seattle
and of course restaurants got crushed
they got completely shut down so now
they're no longer able to have their
main
way of earning money and when canvas was
uh candles was forced to lock down they
started three new businesses they
started a morning delivery
or rather pick up bagel business so
people could drive through they'd have
kind of
right out front of their restaurant
they'd still use their kitchen and
people could get a breakfast bagel
they started a second business was a w
which was a box
lunch business so you could again drive
through grab a box lunch ready to go for
you
and then they started a dinner business
which was a delivery service
where you would get all the things you
need including a nice bottle of wine
to have a dinner prepared for you at
home and they leverage social media to
promote it
they used instagram to promote it and
what they did during dinner was they had
the live piano that you would experience
at this fine dining restaurant
in fact one of our video ranking academy
students
is plays piano for candles and um
and uh you would be able to stream live
piano
to your living room while you ate this
box dinner
um during uh you know with that bottle
of wine and with the mashed potatoes and
everything else
so a door was definitely close for them
but they saw that other doors opened and
they began to innovate
we may not see what that is now but
that's the mindset that we have to be in
is yeah how can we pivot our plan we're
gonna pivot not panic
and we've been continually thinking
about that at think media and you
mentioned
challenges were an innovation for us
we've never done it before and we'd
never done it before so we were super
scary of course we invest in mentors and
and courses and things to teach us how
to do things we've never done and that's
i think one of the reasons why that went
so good because it wasn't like we
reinvented the wheel
um but i also think about we started the
coffee with kennel show that was an
innovation by the way inspired by
probably garyvee because he's just
decided to do a daily show called tea
with garyvee coffee with cannell like
not super creative but innovative for us
we started the think marketing live
show we double down on content and
really challenge as you mentioned omar
and kyle and tony
and nolan to innovate in their video
ideas and to answer specific questions
that matter now
yes people started asking different
questions when
culture changed the questions changed
when culture changed
and so we started to answer different
questions i love that and i think that
innovation
has got to be the theme of 2021
because we're in a rapidly changing
society
culture economy and it doesn't mean that
you can't still survive and prosper but
you may have to be willing to
change and the speed with which you
change and the speed with which you're
willing to change
can give you an edge because most people
hate change and they don't want to do it
quickly
and so the faster you can change the
better which brings us to number five
and you said guard your biggest asset
i'm curious what is our biggest asset i
think your biggest asset
is your heart and your mind i think
being able to guard your heart and guard
your mind
against the things of evil that are
trying to infiltrate
into you so that you aren't productive
so that you aren't
giving back to society right so for me
one of the biggest lessons and one of
the things
i really uh put a lot of focus and
intentionality into
was guarding my heart and my mind so i
mentioned
earlier you know making sure my morning
routine was good hear me
there were a few weeks where i was doom
and gloom where i thought
is this all over is everything we just
worked for done
you know i had that moment and then i
kicked myself
in the you know got myself going and
said no this isn't who we are
we i will until right i can do this
i am a good leader i can weather this
storm and so really shifting
what i'm saying to myself the internal
words that were happening
um for me i went deeper into prayer you
know i'm a woman of faith and i wanted
to lead my family well
alongside my husband and so we really
took to prayer where did god want us to
go how did god want us to lead
through this time um really guarding our
children's heart and mind you know there
is a lot of
messages being thrown at us and so we
wanted to guard our home what were our
children hearing and how are we going to
react to this because
you know our children are watching
whether we see it or not they they see
the fear in us or they see the hope in
us and we wanted to be the light of
jesus at that time
and so we made sure that we were saying
positive things while
negativity was all around us we were
leaning into
what was good and what was great and how
could we overcome
and i think that's the message that i
wanted to live in
during the season of uncertainty um
another thing we did was the 75 hard
challenge
uh you brought this up on a zoom meeting
said i think i'm going to do this and
then the whole team
got on board in some capacity and it was
really great that i didn't finish but it
helped me get back in the routine it
was something like drink a gallon of
water read in the morning you know
get two exercises in we were in a season
where i thought there's no way i'm gonna
get two workouts in
in a day but when i was able to go on
that walk with my kids my husband and be
able to have that time with them and
have some de-stress in the you know
afternoon when i was doing my second
workout
it really helped me to get back into a
consistent routine
our routines were thrown off everyone's
routine was thrown off and so
figuring out what our new idea of how we
wanted to lead and guide our family was
really
important i think the other thing too
was um
you know connecting with other doers was
really important i really when i think
about guarding your heart and your mind
while i do have family members who maybe
disagree with some of my viewpoints and
things
i love them but they weren't the voices
speaking into my life you know i
surrounded myself with other people
who were seeing opportunity who were
overcomers who were
living in hope who were um in community
together
and i think that being around people who
are doers
helps you become a doer it rubs off
right when you're around
people who are seeing opportunity
opportunity becomes a possibility for
you as well and so
i really kept myself and our family
guarded around that
and in a place where we could prosper
i love that and i really feel like i
just want to encourage the think
marketing community
that to even have permission maybe you
feel like you don't have permission to
really invest in yourself with the time
and the energy i think
i know that everybody listening to this
is servant-minded
purpose-driven and is probably a pillar
of strength
for your kids for your family for those
in your life
but sometimes you can almost feel like
all you do is pour
out to everybody else around you but you
need to know
and have permission that you are your
biggest asset
because if you're depleted how can you
pour into your marriage if you're
depleted how can you pour into your kids
if
you're depleted and running on empty how
can you put out the best content
possible
so it can be hard to carve out this time
but this is something that i've been
learning as somebody who likes to run a
million miles an hour
and sometimes just saying yes to every
other task and constantly giving away
i've realized that if my mind is healthy
if my
physical body my mental strength my
spiritual health when i am taking care
of those assets i'm better for everybody
else around me
so have permission to guard your biggest
ass asset and make sure that in 2021
that there is some intentional things
you build into your life because
everyone's going to be better for it
when you rise when you are healthy
healthy things
grow and when you stay healthy and your
heart your soul your mind
you're going to grow the things around
you when you're healthy you're going to
grow your business you're going to grow
your marriage you're going to grow your
kids you're going to grow your home
you're going to grow your finances
if you're in negativity thinking you're
going to grow negativity thinking if
you're impossibility thinking even if
you experience resistance
it's going to be contagious fear
is contagious so is faith faith is
contagious
and in getting into that place of
strength in your inner man inner woman
it's huge and so guard your biggest
asset heather i
love these lessons and i want to hear
from the think marketing community
what lesson did you learn in 2020 that
others could learn from
and maybe something 2020 taught you so
that you can have a better 2021 tell us
in the comments
or please leave us a review on the
podcast and maybe this episode or
another episode encouraged you
please share it and heather thank you so
much for the wisdom today
well those were my five lessons that i
learned over 2020. it has been
such a year but i'm actually looking
forward to 2021 i am
definitely nervous about all the changes
that are happening but at the same time
like i said we need to know that change
is the only
constant now if you are new to the
podcast make sure to subscribe and
share this with a friend if you know
someone who wants to grow on youtube or
is ready to start or grow their online
business we are here to help them as
well we cover
everything youtube as well as online
business and
all the marketing strategies that you
would need to grow your business
this year and beyond now after you're
done listening to
this episode i think your next action
should be to go over and take
our one hour free youtube class if
you're ready to grow
a business on youtube this year then you
should watch this free one hour class
over at thinkmasterclass.com during this
one hour class you're gonna learn
the three secrets to youtube success how
we've been able to
surpass over a million subscribers and
how you can get views and subscribers on
your
channel this year with one strategy that
sean cannell
teaches so head over to
thinkmasterclass.com right now to
register
and get instant access to our free one
hour
youtube class also if you have not
gone over to apple itunes and rated and
reviewed this podcast
my request is that you do that sometime
today
and we love to shout out our different
listeners from the think
community and today is from vegas kid
joe he said most helpful information
sean cannell continues to bring the most
insightful and useful information
for creators i will surely be a long
time subscriber and
listener vegas kid joe thank you so much
for being a part of our community and
for
all of you listeners who have been here
with us since the beginning we just want
to say thank you so much
you mean the world to us and we are
obsessed with your success so let us
know
over on apple itunes when you rate and
review the podcast
how your channel has grown from the
information that you've learned here
on the podcast well in our next episode
we go into the second part
where sean shares five lessons that he
learned from 2020. you're going to want
to stay tuned for that
he gets real raw and vulnerable
sharing some numbers and some big
insights that he learned
from the crazy year we just had here at
think
thanks so much for listening and we'll
catch you on the next episode
[Music]
bye
you